During this lesson, we focused on the map reduced
programming model. A very common open source implementation of
the map reduce programming model is HADOOP. HADOOP couples
the map reduce programming model with a distributed file system.
In order to more easily allow programmers to complete
complicated tasks using the processing power of HADOOP, there
are many infrastructures out there that either built on
top of HADOOP, Or allow data access via Hadoop. Two
of the most common are Hive and Pig. Hive was
initially developed by FaceBook, and one of its biggest selling
points is that it allows you to run map-produced jobs
through a SQL-like querying language, called the Hive Query Language.
Pig was originally developed at Yahoo! And excels in some
areas Hive does not. Pig jobs are written in a
procedural language called pig Latin. This wins you a bunch
of things. Among them are the ability to be more explicit
about the execution of your data processing. Which
is not possible in a declarative language like SQL
syntax. And also the ability to split your data
pipeline. Hive and Pig are two of the most
common Hadoop-based products, but there are a bunch
of them out there. For example Mahout for machine
learning, Giraph for graph analysis, and Cassandra, a hybrid
of a key value and a column oriented database.